that we are not able to do these things
but we want to do those things
[Music]
detector Point uh that you guys finished
your
today
you know you talk about morality and
about economical choice I think uh from
my experience one one good angle to take
on this might still be helping we have
to put them on the platform because the
question is hello
when they're saying this is something
right it should be allowed to be open
and they say no we can't screw it wrong
so on any on any issue who who's
rectified right or wrong
and when you break that down if you look
if you if you say
then the fundamentally depending on
where you're from what your experiences
are in your life people are going to be
from what what you think will come from
your mind what you think is right what
you think is wrong for us obviously we
say it's Allah
no I mean if you could if you can prove
as a Creator and he's the one who
created it and he's all knowing all
knowledgeable Thanos and he made us and
also he knows what's right and wrong for
better than the creation itself so
ultimately the discussion comes back to
that point which is I think that's
really right but let me tell you
something let's be let's be completely
honest yeah
let's be totally honest
let me give you two
thought experiments okay two thought
expands
if somebody is a white man in England
like not even okay he comes to one of
our sisters hijab
and in a very gentle and nice way
he says listen I just want to ask you a
question of sincerity
and authenticity why do you wear this
on your head
and then she starts answering she says
look we believe in God we believe that
you know this is happening and you know
God is telling us these things are right
he uses things are wrong whatever yeah
is there anything unusual about what
I've just said like if any of you are
privy to that conversation would you
consider that to be an unusual
conversation
no okay that's socially acceptable and
it's respectful whatever yeah
if I was to give you a full experiment
too
Muslim man maybe looks like me
and he approaches two
lesbians
in the streets holding hands
I said please
just
hold on for a second I have a question
are you in a relationship with each
other
Etc okay whatever you know yes yes we
are
can I ask you to tell me why
you believe it's okay to be in a
relationship like that
some of them would say it's none of your
business I I prom I promise you the
majority of them will say it's none of
your business and that that unsafe they
said it's none of your business would be
socially acceptable correct would you
accept would you do that but if the
Muslim says it's none of your business
it would be seen as a little bit rude
now the reason why I'm saying these two
things is we are expected to Bow and
bend over backwards for the white man
yeah
yeah that's the truth of the matter we
are voila we are and what I'm saying is
that sometimes you just don't need to
offer a single justification
and that's where the height of
confidence is
I I tell you I've been doing this in my
life
uh with certain people uh not people who
I considered to be sincere but they'll
come to me especially you know the Press
although because I've been getting a tax
recently
and I've been answering the most and
they don't know how to I can guarantee
you this is a very effective strategy
they'll say why did you say this and
whatever why did you do this and why are
you doing this wherever it may be and
sometimes the best answer is this this
is this one yeah because I want to
thank you
my life
because I want to what if you think
about it really carefully just for a
second how can you refute that
because I want to it's almost
irrefutable
what are you going to say oh what you
shouldn't want to why now if now if they
get into this why do you want to tell
these labor businesses so it goes back
to that right what I'm saying is
sometimes we just have to we this is
inventing a new culture what made the
Civil Rights Movement so successful in
1960s
with black people in particular is
because they had an attitude shift it
wasn't necessarily because they had the
best intellectual arguments
it's because they were willing to change
their attitude from a servile submissive
slavish attitude yeah we'll take it from
the back we'll give it give it flog me
yeah no problem so you know what no
actually what are you talking about and
it was in that it was that attitudinal
shift
which created the change for us we don't
need to learn we don't need to learn
arguments
we need to change attitudes
because because
if we want to win them and convince them
that's a different story that's a
different story yeah remember we started
the premise here is if they are not
sincere it's just sincere like these
Latin Americans have been seeing around
coming honestly asking me any questions
yeah we have to we have a duty of care
but if they're coming and and you know
we are human beings we have a certain
level of for us so we have a certain
level on the psychological understanding
you know who is the world we're sure the
sincere one from is trying to leverage
you and manipulate you and antagonize
you and that's why Allah
he says
if you want to protect yourself in the
Dunya
you have to have the ISA which is why
it's a famous poet he said
with the Japanese boy don't take it
literally he said
kill them
whoever doesn't impressive people will
be oppressed again no meaning
if you don't act Mighty and tough and
rough they're gonna they're gonna do it
with you so are they gonna be the
shepherd or the Sheep you're going to
deal with or you're gonna get dealt with
that's why I'm talking to that
you know it's attacking super Cafe
Republic
you know he said you use your swords let
it be the hakka in the in the next of
the uh of the individuals who like your
opponents
and if you go to a place of humiliation
then leave the place
if you see someone who's oppressive then
be oppressive with them yeah once again
be rough with the rough man be wild with
the wild one
and if you see the one who's Wild guy
they'll be even more well with them so
we need to just remember
it's our attitude that needs to change
these guys they shouldn't be asking us
questions like why do you believe the
homosexual if they're coming at you with
roughness
then just remember come at them what do
you mean why not this and that what do
you mean why did you believe it's okay
no you explain yourself
we're not the defendant and then the
plating the plaintiff
they're not the judge who wears their
own trial none of that is applicable to
them so I think if we change the
attitude a lot of people follow